a la crisis sanitaria empeora en
mariupol el alcalde de la ciudad
advirtió este miércoles que miles de
personas pueden morir por enfermedades
bacterianas en una situación precaria
incluso la onu ha llegado a la
conclusión de que es posible que haya un
brote de cólera y otras enfermedades
como la disentería
desafortunadamente esto podría acabar
con la vida de muchos de nuestros
residentes
riding boychenko achacó la situación de
la falta de agua potable de comida y
medicamentos también al entrenamiento
masivo y caótico de los más de 20.000
civiles que según el alcalde habrían
sido asesinados por el ejército ruso las
lluvias y la contaminación de las
fuentes hídricas por los cadáveres
habrían hecho el resto el agua ha lavado
esas tumbas y desafortunadamente esto
también es parte del tema con la
epidemiología y el medio ambiente porque
toda esta agua sucia y las cosas que
acabo de mencionar todo esto se está
moviendo caóticamente hacia los ríos y
hacia el mar por lo tanto será un
problema grave en verano entretanto o
rusia anunció nuevas rendiciones de
soldados en la sitiada planta de asustar
seiscientos noventa y cuatro soldados
incluyendo 29 heridos se han rendido en
este pasado día
959 en total desde el 16 de mayo
incluyendo 80 heridos
sin embargo se cree que los comandantes
siguen dentro de la planta sin rendirse
así lo reporta la agencia de noticias
local del puerto de asof citando al
líder separatista pro ruso denis puccini
por su parte quien insiste en que no
fueron bendiciones sino evacuaciones y
dijo que espera negociar un intercambio
de prisioneros